[Musique]
première règle de la diplomatie la
vérité n'est pas une question de fait
une question de consensus
[Musique]
michael sullivan votre prédécesseur
était sensible rif et le sous-secrétaire
de main de ce qui lui est arrivé
accident de voiture que ça va non il est
mort
j'ai choisi ce poste parce que j'ai
envie de faire avancer les choses le
type qui dirige les opérations là bas
n'est pas très orthodoxe il ne faut
surtout pas le sous-estimer
vous avez deux minutes michael justin
cocker cia je ne vais pas espionné pour
vous ouvrez simplement les yeux et les
oreilles
bagdad est le centre de l'univers les
plus grands organes du renseignement
sont tous là tout le monde cherche à
troquer ses secrets ou ccrbistes
l'information est le nerf de la guerre
observés écoutés apprenez
bonsoir nous admirons beaucoup le
travail que vous accomplissez pour les
irakiens
vous n'avez pas me remercier je fais ce
que j'ai à faire bien passé une bonne
soirée
n'oubliez pas votre enveloppe
c'est un homme dangereux le jeune
diplomate rien ne peut marcher sans son
entremise est dangereux d'être dans ce
coin de désert perdu sans escorte il
agit sous les ordres qui secoue pékin
les fonds spéculatifs saddam la mafia
ils ont une liste contenant des noms de
personnes qui touchent toutes tes
baudevin de saddam
on parle de gens très hauts placés qui
détournent des millions de dollars et si
c'était une taupe faut vous méfier de
moi j'ai une vidéo de vous avec lui en
train de vous remettre un peu de fard
jackson appel concernant votre
interprète cia le mi5 interpol cette
fille a un paquet d'admirateurs qu'est
ce qu'elle veut que vous fassiez rien
[Musique]
vous m'avez demandé de mettre ma
carrière en jean
[Musique]
vous devez faire confiance
je crois que je les vous étude que vous
n'avez rien à mourir
j'en fais
on se bat pas contre la tempête
[Musique]
pas mal mon gars ont bien joué